we're at the fell Cena winery in Chianti
and this is chiara yes this is my friend
Jordan and for many years he has talked
about one of his favorite wines which
comes from this vineyard and so now I've
brought you here this is a magic moment
for you so maybe you thank you yeah
thank you dick well I always think the
wait don't hold it that's annoying
that's annoying me does it smell good or
not I won't cut your goddamn hand off as
annoying stop it first base is the
condom
so you can see the caller you might be
able to see your finger through it yes
yes Jordan hold yours Hey and see if you
can see my finger see see that
it's important that's important this is
another son Joseph gentle perch
anticipation across the state he does
bother I've told you like eight times
this is fantastic
maybe you drank the whole thing you were
supposed to spill this something it out
why well you seem to become intoxicated
you won't be able to add it strength
mine watch this it's a magic trick I
learned in alcoholism school Wow she got
it tingly is a wild boar oh why are the
primary meats of Tuscany
meat is often greasy and a Koecher
tongue drinking this after cleans your
tongue it's your favorite wine mmm and
it does seem to pair well with boar so
and then is Malik and immediately have
these notes of Troy
chattering and blood food I don't
concentrate on the fruit I concentrate
on the earth and I smell a forest
I mean I feel like I'm lost in the woods
right now
like when you're walking in the woods
and maybe well not even the soil yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we've got nothing to drinking we're
behaving this way I want your help the
dogs will come in on your powdered puss
of all the wine tastings you've done is
this the stupidest one maybe not stupid
but different very different much better
she didn't say better I said I know you
said a lot of stuff you're lost in the
woods you're running around with a ma
stick up your ass
what your problem and some age the wine
I'm not had mine
let's see now that's it that is it just
a fantastic wine if I was one of these
three wines I would be the font to Laura
because I am a subtle you know so you
have to look deep yeah you know you are
a right upfront in your face
initially and then that's it yeah and
there's no more so then you get it all
at one you know what we finally agree
you are like the frontal or Oh in that I
would like to push you into a barrel and
seal it and then wait 20 years enjoy
what's left of you chichi salute legacy
you should never hold a wine glass like
that that's a Buddha Buddha that is
inelegant you're getting a disgusting
greasy fingerprints on this beautiful
glass I don't want to see your
disgusting greasy fingerprints when I
look at that glass there's no job
waiting for you in there you'll become a
hobo and wander Tuscany it he just
called me stupid and Gracie and a friend
doesn't do that to the friend I say your
fingerprints are stupid ain't you made
your face
[Applause]
you